he is one of the all-time greats in the
history of this sport held the
heavyweight and light heavyweight world
championship simultaneously and he was
at the mic for UFC 248 he's Daniel
Cormier back on the show how are you DC
I'm doing pretty good
I'm doing fine what'd you think of that
weekend sir what'd you think well you
know we had some good we had some weird
normal night the UFC you know we had we
had some good fights that's you had some
great fights and then we had that weird
main event you know so it was it was
like a normal day in the life with us
the commentators yeah you know I was
gonna ask you where oughta Sonya versus
Romero fell on that on that scale of
adjectives and you place it in the weird
why do you place it in the weird sir man
did you see I mean if you watch the
fight you saw the very first minute and
a half you all just kind of stood there
with his hands up and he's so
frightening that he almost froze is me
without even doing I throwing anything
and then honestly it just kind of stayed
that way it was it was one of those
fights where you kind of were
anticipating the the explosion the
fireworks and it just never came you
know you got 25 minutes of of
essentially cat-and-mouse you know and
uh it was just weird man it was a weird
fight it was it reminds me of a fight
way back in the day Anderson Silva
fought in in Saudi Arabia and it was one
of those nights that just did not turn
out to be what everyone expected so
there are some who might be holding out
asagna to account for that fight being
weird where do you stand on that subject
I don't I don't you know rich when you
fight your Romero a guy that has knocked
out so many people a guy that has really
fought in that same exact way but finds
ways to end fights with with one action
you cannot think that Izzy was just go
in there and be reckless you know I've
never seen anyone do it and he did what
he had to do I mean this guy's the
champion he's a guy that if you're
willing to engage you know you uh he'll
give you your type of fight but Yolo
Romero is not a guy that you want
be out there being reckless with he's
just too dangerous the the the risk it's
not worth the danger that it takes to go
out there and just be reckless we met
out asagna of last year and twice he
came by in our studio and he lit it up
like we could have turned the lights off
and his his energy and his his
personality could have powered the
entire studio I loved meeting him I
loved seeing what he what he what he
does he's a showman he's an entertainer
but how far do you think he can go in
his career Daniel you know rich I think
that he can be as big a star as you had
the UFC you know some guys just have it
you know it's like you said it just
radiates off of them you get did you
just see it from the moment he walked
into the Octagon he essentially marked
his territory and you saw a young kid
who had never done anything become a
champion in 90 year and that doesn't
happen very often in the UFC and I think
that's just one of those nights I mean
you know Anderson Silva it did not
really effective legacy having that
night in Saudi Arabia I think that's
going to be the case for Izzy I think
he's just going to move forward and and
his next fight is guaranteed to deliver
because the guys fighting Paul Acosta
has never been in a fight like you saw
is yet less so how do you how do you how
do your handicap going right now first
blush that's a close fight man I think
Paul Acosta he's a guy that says forget
the risk and fighting over Maryland he
just went right at him it was the same
night that I fought over Anaheim and it
was a explosive fight but it's hard to
pick against the champ right now but I
do believe that this is the most real
challenge that he's had since becoming
the champion or winning the interim
championship I know that's why with
Kelvin Gastelum was super close but I
mean this guy's a beast man out of
Brazil and it's gonna be a fun one well
and in terms of his plans he couldn't
have he couldn't have been autist on you
could not have been more graphic in his
description about he would contends to
do to John Jones and not only do to John
Jones he knows exactly where he wants it
to happen he wants it to happen in the
new Raider stadium and he wants it to
the next summer and he's envisioning
this I mean he could not have been more
point blank about it what do you think
of that scenario DC I mean you know big
gold right you know the last guy we saw
to pretty much try to call this shot or
call the shot was kind of McGregor and
look at what that what happened to
Connor I mean I just think that is needs
to really stay focus on what he has to
do you know I get it
you know you start looking at the big
fish you start looking at the big
picture when you become a champion and
defend the championship but I think the
challenge that that that's in front of
him right now it's so dangerous
so big then you have to focus or he's
gonna find himself in and in overtaking
Paul Acosta this guy is this guy is so
freakishly scary I mean if you could see
a picture of him right you feel like
yeah I would never look past the guy
paul across there's a beast and i think
it needs to focus on that and when the
time comes and him and jones fight is
gonna be fun so you can right now he's
that business you can understand the
Animus he has towards Jones Daniel yeah
of course I mean it's easy to just like
John Jones I mean it's not it's not a
it's not hard and Jones has really made
it be a target and I think that Jenna
Sonia is one of those new-age guys rich
that you know he he he does not like
challenges and he does not pull any
punches when it comes to a fight
building Daniel Cormier here on the Rich
Eisen show you just alluded to it in
terms of Conor calling a shot and got a
little bit too much more than he wanted
Kabhi back in the Octagon it's gonna
happen in about five weeks time against
Tony Ferguson what do you think of that
fight how about is gonna play out great
fight
that is a great fight I mean that is
probably the biggest fight that we can
make in the UFC right now you got have
even a mega Met Office's a guy in a 28
no means no mistakes and Tony Ferguson
has not lost in eight years so I think
this is the Connors talent that Connor
is the biggest star in the UFC but I
think when you look at the two most
skillful guys at 155 pounds it doesn't
get much better than hobby even Tony and
I think you get the tube great two of
the greatest lightweights of all time is
on in a port Brooklyn and and this is a
fun fight I mean I'm to be teammate and
I know for the longest time in house we
have felt that this is the most
dangerous fight for him and I'm excited
for him to finally get it done so how
would you have handled it if your belt
got kicked in a press conference as
Kabir did to Ferguson last Friday how
would you handle that if your belt got
kicked in a in a in a pre fight hype
fight right there you know but you know
Tony's a guy that that just kind of he
looked like it didn't bother me I think
calling what's read press conference was
the idea that he was going to agitate
hobbies and I feel when Habib picked the
belt he almost gave Tony exactly what he
wanted right he let Tony know that he
was kind of upsetting him and that uh I
feel like you know whether I'll be able
to push them or or you know gotten
gotten angry or in this case take the
belt that's the exact reaction that Tony
was looking for so I feel like he didn't
get upset I feel like he was very happy
he feels like he got a win there couple
of minutes left with Daniel Cormier here
in the Rich Eisen show I think you saw
the video of you and Joe Rogan going
viral right did you see the reaction did
you know you were on camera when you
were you were reacting to the the
clothes knockout you know rich we they
usually have a commentator camp so you
know it yeah but don't said the greatest
thing the other day and he goes with
just professional fans right we're fans
of the sport that just are lucky enough
to be able to call the fight and it was
it was it was just it was crazy because
but now's our you had your Carlos's back
the whole first round almost submitted
them then you're Carl Ertz them very bad
he's looking to finish and then Vanille
hits them on the side of the head right
and get some all wobbly chicken leg
starts running back to start exchanges
and then BOOM and then the visual
Richard saw his mouthpiece is halfway
out of his mouth eyes are rolling back
in his head it was I mean one of the
best ones that I've ever seen sitting
next to the side of the Octagon but it
was all paled in comparison to the
fight between Jung and Jung Joo check
right I mean that was the ladies had had
had the evening yeah your honor yunjae
Tekken and Wei Li Zhong put on the best
fight that I've seen in a long time rich
it's going to go down yes I wanted a
greatest title fight in US history four
hundred significant strikes were landed
between these two women it was insane
and then the CEO on his head at the end
of it it was worse than I've seen
walkman I think before last Saturday
nobody had a bigger hematoma
then Hasim Rahman had and his title
fight a while back right but this this
thing was crazy do we know how she is
today you know you know here's the thing
about that right like in the moment it
hurts very bad right but all that
swelling goes down pretty quick you know
they parted to go to the hospital
it was confident a constant question and
I'm sure it probably went down pretty
fast but in the fight every time she got
hit I'm sure her brain was feeling and
her head was feeling it no matter where
she took contact she was feeling and on
that that that spot okay and how are you
feeling you good good yeah I'm good I'm
just waiting for that that fight against
be pay you know waiting to uh try to
correct the wrong of last summer I I
tell my I told a UFC and and and my
management team I said don't ever offer
me a fight again in Anaheim California
I love SoCal I love being over there but
there has not been a guy at UFC history
to lose more championship belt in the
Honda Center do not offer me a fight
then I'm on $30 okay so what is the
latest on that know what do you know
words waiting on me oh [ __ ] you know he
had some injuries after the last fight
we beat each other up pretty good over
there right and we're trying to see when
he's ready to go but we're looking at
the summer and it's starting to sound
more and more like we'll have something
pretty sick here in the next week are
you working with George Foreman right
now Daniel I am no what's that I promise
you it it's crazy and you know George
was 47 when he won the heavyweight title
I'm gonna be 41 years old
I'm like if anybody understands trying
to train as an older athlete its George
Foreman and it was good in cook I love
being around George and we talked boxing
we talked em
initially I was starstruck and then
realized that George is out of his mind
George vs MMA George you can't believe
it right so is the Daniel Cormier grill
not too far behind as well we can all
get that going
get that guy rich if I get my grill can
still happen with the Foreman grill sold
I'd be at alright man well thanks for
calling in Daniel we'll get you back on
soon obviously to 49s right around the
corner and it was fun hearing you at the
mic as always thank you so much rich I
appreciate you guys don't be a stranger
that's Daniel Cormier at DC underscore
MMA on both Twitter and Instagram one of
the most popular fighters of all time
right here on the Rich Eisen show